[Musique]
je m'appelle paul ou jacques je suis né
en egypte
je suis devenu à la fois journaliste de
radio et romancière
[Musique]
on pense que ce sont des romans
autobiographiques
parce que beaucoup de mes livres se
passe en egypte en israël où j'ai vécu
une certaine partie du temps mais en
fait pas du tout je prends des émotions
décide des bouts de situations que j'ai
vécu et je les place dans des intrigues
complètement différente que je n'ai
jamais vécu ou même à une époque que je
n'ai pas connu
donc mes personnages reflètent un peu ça
ce sont toujours des personnages qui ne
sont pas les gros ils sont assez
complexes mais ils sont toujours aux
prises avec les difficultés de
l'existence le quotidien quand il se
fait menaçant
un écrivain n'a pas de sexe quand il
écrit je veux dire il est à la fois le
personnage masculin
la petite fille la femme le chien de la
petite fille voilà donc on est un petit
peu multiples quand on écrit les beaux
c'est une passion sans fin les mots en
français
c'est tout ce dont j'ai été prise et
quand je me suis retrouvé en israël
pendant trois ans dans un kibboutz il
fallait que j'oublie tout du passé que
je laisse tomber le français que je
laisse tomber mes livres pour apprendre
l'hébreu cette langue tellement rude
[Musique]
peut-être qu'il ya un vieux préjugés une
vieille halle et aliénation même chez le
jury féminin des grand prix féminin moi
j'appartiens au jury du femina et
peut-être qu'effectivement on est on a
un peu plus de mal à récompenser les
femmes c'est vrai que ce n'est pas juste
que par exemple il ya beaucoup plus
d'hommes que de femmes qui obtiennent le
goncourt mais je suis persuadé que ça va
changer
peut-être que je suis trop optimistes
d'ailleurs de tous temps vous savez au
19e siècle les grandes romancières
anglaises c'était des femmes s'étaient
déjà nos stents c'était les soeurs
broutilles et vous savez qu'à l'époque
elle publié sous un nom féminin masculin
avait été obligé une femme est capable
maintenant tout comme un homme
d'embrasser le vaste monde avec toute sa
complexité ses faits politiques ces
problèmes
et voilà donc je suis assez optimiste là
dessus
[Musique]